hello I'm Tom I'm Simon and welcome to
crash course cries fear the cries fear
is the part of the earth system where
water exists in solid form so that could
be snow river ice sea ice glaciers even
the polar caps the cryosphere covers a
significant part of the Earth's surface
and is a significant influence on
climate so it's important that we
understand it in this series we're going
to be teaching you about the science of
ice and also trying to provide some
historical context to its study I'm
going to be here in the library at the
Scott Polar Research Institute talking
about how maths and physics influence
our understanding of the cryosphere I'm
going to be here in the Scott Polar
Research Institute's lecture theater to
talk to you about the science of ice and
I'm also going to be here in the museum
and the archive at the Institute talking
to the head curator and looking at
artifacts that shed some light on a
history of our understanding of the
cryosphere so that's what you've got to
look forward to in this series but to
kick us off on this episode I'm going to
be looking at the physics of how
substances change from liquid to solid
I'll be looking at where the water on
Earth has come from I'll be dampening a
little bit in how water turns to ice as
well cue the intro
[Music]
to get us started both in an icy sense
and a serious sense where does water
come from why is there water on earth
and how much is there elsewhere in the
solar system well this is how much water
we think is in the solar system now
these are some pretty rough estimates
that we've put together here and
certainly doesn't include every single
potential body that has water what we're
doing this in is in earth units so one
earth unit of water in this case is
about 200 milliliters now what else have
we got elsewhere in the solar system
well on the moon we actually have traces
of water this is very much not to scale
this one and it's ice in the craters on
the poles of the moon on Mars the red
planet we have naught point five earth
units worth of water now Mars is
particularly interesting because this
waters locked up in glaciers at both
poles this is not any very cool for us
as Gracie ologists examines our work is
suddenly relevant not just on earth but
also on Mars the blue plant itself earth
with one earth unit worth of water and
then we have you rope up one of the
moons of Jupiter this has 2.5 earth
units of water and is largely an icy
ball which is completely covered in
solid ice effectively we think sea ice
covering a vast ocean and here we have
the one I can never pronounce but this
time we will go for eggplant ears
Enceladus I will someday remember this
thank you so much and here we have five
earth units water and that's very
similar to Europa and that it's an icy
moon and finally we have Ganymede which
is a very new data on here and we're not
really sure what's going on except we
know there's ten possibly there's a
pretty rough guess but maybe ten earth
units of water from all of this we can
see that whilst the earth is special in
terms of harboring a life in terms of
water there's actually a lot of it else
around the slowness system and a lot of
it's in an icy state as with Mars this
is a great news for those of us who
study the cryosphere
as this means that our work is not only
relevant on our earth but it's relevant
across the solar system there are a
number of competing hypotheses which are
not mutually exclusive as to where all
the water on Earth has come from the
first of these is exoplanetary origins
so this is from asteroids or proto
planets impacting on the Earth's surface
during its early formation
we actually know that most of the water
on Earth came very early on in the
Earth's lifecycle and we know this by
comparing hydrogen isotopes between the
moon asteroids on earth which indicate
that yes most water on earth is actually
very old a hydrogen isotope is just a
hydrogen atom but with a different
number of neutrons in the nuclei
this means it has the same chemical
properties but just a different atomic
weight the second hypothesis is that not
all water on Earth came from
exoplanetary objects then at least some
of the water must have come from the
earth itself there are two reasons for
this the first of these is that not all
of the excess planetary objects that
impacted on the earth will have brought
water with them this reduces the chance
of the overall water body being all
exoplanetary in addition to this it's
been found that the ratio of hydrogen
isotopes on comets is about double that
of oceanic water this strongly suggests
that these warr - but separate bodies
have different sources of water on them
a couple of suggested earth-centered
sources of water include the leakage of
water from hydrated minerals and even
more awesomely bacteria very early on in
the Earth's lifecycle there was a very
exotic bacteria that had very weird
energy gaining pathways the byproducts
of which may have been water
however the bacteria one was exceedingly
cool is unlikely to be a major source a
third sort of mini hypothesis has
recently come out of some really cool
research on Baffin Island there they
found that the water in the lavas is
quite possibly pre-solar this means it's
been around since before the formation
of our solar system let alone the earth
it suggested that possibly this water
entered the area via dust grains onto
which it had been absorbed of course
this is probably a very small source of
water but it's very interesting and very
cool to know that actually some of the
water on earth can be very very ancient
indeed in predating even the existence
of our solar system we'll be returning
to Tom later in the episode but speaking
of history is time for us to take our
first trip to the archives of the
Institute what do you do well so the
museum is part of the Scott Polar
Research Institute and we have a
collection of things related to the
polar regions we were founded in 1920
and it was set up as a place the whole
Institute was I suppose a place
for exchanging knowledge and also
equipment and so that's where the start
of the collection came from and now we
have a public museum anyone can visit
for free and we've got lots of our
collections on display and my job is
really making sure that they're cared
for properly stored properly and that we
get them out as often as we can for
people to look at or to do research with
so what do we have in front of us here
well this is a walrus
skull so the walrus as you probably know
is a very large Arctic mammal and it's
one of the many objects in the
collection that was collected for
scientific study now actually we don't
know a great deal about this like many
museums we've got an awful lot of things
in storage and some of them we know a
lot about and then others we hardly know
anything about at all and this is one
example it's something that was maybe
found in someone's office and then got
offered to us so we know it's a walrus
school but beyond that not a huge amount
really so you don't know the provenance
no and most of our objects we do know
something about I mean what most people
don't realize is that for most museums
we only have about 10% of our collection
on display at any one time and the rest
sits in store for people to come and do
research so it's available to come and
look at and maybe someone could come and
tell us more about it exactly where it
came from or perhaps what happened to it
and why it passed away but yeah beyond
that we don't really know an awful lot
but it's clearly been looked after it's
got some screws in it and things that's
been held together and maybe displayed
at some point in its history so this is
one large Arctic mammal but we're
talking about the Christ fear in this
series a lot as if it's like some inert
object it's not it's a living
environment and we have another item
here we do yeah
bigger than the room I think so this is
a tusk or a narwhal which is another
large arctic mammal the narwhals part of
the whale family so it's quite closely
related to beluga whales and this is
actually a tooth it's one of its incisor
teeth but over yeah pretty much used for
showing off I think largely so their
main diet is actually Cod and halibut so
clearly it's not designed for capturing
we can smear a few on there yeah yeah
lack of opposable thumbs might make that
a bit tricky for them yeah it was mostly
used for fighting between the males so
how did this come into the
collection center well this is actually
a recent addition and it's part of our
handling collection rather than the
historic collection because we've
already had some narwhal tusks and it
came from Greenland so we've got quite a
lot of information the person who
brought it in gave his map from where it
was collected and it was collected by
someone who was on an expedition doing a
completely different kind of science and
they found this on the beach and thought
nah it's too good I'll have that so they
collected it sadly that individual died
a few years ago and his wife donated it
to us so it's gonna be part of our
handling collection and go on to help us
educate all the people that come through
our doors over the years and is that
something that commonly happens then you
get people to do an expedition and come
back with things they weren't expecting
to find yeah I think that's pretty
common and in fact the hardest part of
my job probably is saying no to things
because people have collected so much
stuff over the years and we have to be
able to store it properly
so exactly we have to turn down lots of
really wonderful things that we just
don't have space for which is a bit of a
shame
yeah isn't it we'll be returning to the
archives next week but right now it's
time to go back to Tom who wants to talk
about one of the most fundamental
processes in the cryosphere so now we
have our water but how does that water
become ice and how does that ice becomes
snow and how does that snow then become
a glacier well yes it just has to freeze
but actually when he starts look at the
detail things are of course a little bit
more complicated without external
influences water in the atmosphere will
actually only freeze at around minus 36
degrees Celsius this is because minus 36
is actually the freezing point of truly
pure water of course in nature it's very
rare for us to get pure water and
there's actually a number of ways in
which we can have water freezing from
somewhere between nought degrees Celsius
and minus 36 degrees Celsius one of the
ways since we can get water to freeze at
higher temperatures than minus 36 is by
having particles in the water droplets
this is a process known as nucleation
examples of such nucleating centres
include things like black carbon dust
and even microbes interestingly is
actually these biological sources that
can probably get water to freeze at the
highest temperature this is because
fundamentally they have a higher surface
area due to all their little spikes and
stuff as compared to the smooth
particles of carbon or whatever that's
not only will a cold around my sphere
lead to small snow but a colder and
dusty atmosphere
took more snow was not only meeting the
threshold for freezing easier but you
also have more material around which the
ice crystals can nucleate this
relationship between water availability
and nucleation sources is one of the
reasons why you get polar deserts now
we're very used to thinking of deserts
in terms of hot places but actually you
get them a lot in the cryosphere as well
particularly in antarctica one of the
reasons why the Antarctic Dry Valleys
exists it was not only is all the water
around them locked up in the ice but
also that ice is on top of the land
which prevents dust from being released
and obviously there's relatively little
of microbial life or things exacting
pollen into the air around which ice in
the atmosphere could then nucleate and
then fall to earth therefore you end up
with Antarctic Dry Valleys which are
actually one of the driest places on
earth
and have been taken increasing by
scientists as good place to study as a
proxy for Mars now unfortunately at this
point we're probably going to have to
break out some physics thanks Tom now in
order to talk about water going from
solid to liquid and vice-versa we need
to talk about phase transitions phase is
kind of another word for what we call
the state of a substance a substance
like water can have different states
that can be solid liquid or gas and what
defines a state is a consistent set of
molecular interactions over a large set
of space so in a solid as we have in our
water molecule model over here this is
water molecules arranged in a
crystalline configuration that we call
ice there are lots of very strong bonds
between the molecules within the lattice
or within the ice structure if we were
to melt that bit of ice then the bonds
between the molecules would be much
weaker they'd be jostling around but
still connected to each other whereas if
we were to transition that that liquid
into a gas then there be far fewer
interactions between the molecules and
they'd be flying around floating freely
we can represent where a particular
substance like water is in these states
using what we call a phase diagram which
we have up here so we have along our
x-axis temperature and along our y-axis
pressure what this simply tells us then
is say we're in a room we're about 20
degrees Celsius and we're at atmospheric
pressure so about 1,000 hex Pascal's or
a thousand millibars what we can do then
is trace along our temperature and our
pressure and we can see that water is
most thermodynamically
stable in these conditions as a liquid
that's all this diagram is it shows you
where the most thermodynamically stable
point is now each region here to refers
to a different state of matter so solid
liquid or gas and where there's a
boundary between the two it's possible
for for example water to exist as ice
and as liquid water under the same
conditions let's say them that we
decrease the temperature in this room on
our diagram this is equivalent to us
putting a point here where we are and
then moving it to the left as the
temperature decreases and decreases
until we reach the line between where
water is most thermodynamically stable
as a liquid and where it's most stable
as a solid that line is known as a phase
transition and while there's a certain
amount of energy that's associated with
moving the temperature to the left and
decrease in the temperature if we want
to change our water from liquid solid
then we need a certain amount of extra
energy that we call latent energy or
latent heat to get those bonds between
the molecules going now in this case
going from liquid to solid is actually
what's known as an exothermic reaction
so by the water molecules snapping into
a crystalline structure it emits energy
into its surroundings so we end up from
going from this chaotic disordered state
into this very regular state that we
have over in a molecule model on the
left so the key takeaway from this then
is that water can exist in different
states and in order to transition from
one state to another you require an
extra little bit of energy and as the
latent energy back to you Tom the newly
formed ice crystal is caused heavier
than the air around it and so it starts
to fall to earth as it falls down it
will usually pass through more humid
layers of air and start to pick up more
water around it
however this water is added in a very
structured manner you'll always have a
six-sided hexagonal crystal so no matter
how big your snowflake gets it will
always have six sides even though you've
formed snow high up in the Earth's
atmosphere it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're gonna get snow on the ground
this is because there could be warmer
air masses below where you've formed
your snow that will melt it as it passes
through therefore in order to get snow
on the ground you need pool air all the
way down so we have our frozen water in
the sky falling to earth but what
happens once it reaches the ground and
how do these small little ice crystals
become gigatonnes worth of glaciers that
carve valleys
entire continents and changed climate as
we know it well that's what we're going
to look at in the next nine episodes in
this episode we've covered that the
cryosphere is any part of the Earth's
system where water is frozen this
includes sea ice the polar caps and
glaciers that's why we're considering
the Earth's cry sphere Isis everywhere
in the solar system that water freezes
at a bunch of different temperatures
depending on the pressure and
temperature the water is experiencing
and other factors like nucleation and
lastly the for water to freeze it must
undergo a phase transition with
Associated latent energy well that's all
we have time for this week but before
you go and like this video which you
totally should by the way in the
description the first link is to a
questionnaire and then we'd like you to
go and click on a link and fill it out
the reason it's there is because we want
to know how much you know about the
cryosphere at the start of this series
so by the end of the series we'll give
you another questionnaire and see how
effective this series was in teaching
you so go and answer those questions and
we'll see you at that link again or one
very similar to it in about nine weeks
time thank you for watching and we'd
also like to thank these people up here
who made this series possible and in
particular the recover project at the
University of Exeter who gave us funding
and the Scott Polar Research Institute
here in Cambridge for accommodating us
thank you for watching and we'll see you
for more icy adventures next week
you